aujourd'hui refaire un petit âne boxing
petit mano grande boxing day
d'alcooliques j'ai reçu c'est ce truc là
et dans ce truc là vous avez un
smartphone de gaming des accessoires une
chose pour l'air vraiment top c'est le
rock phone 2 j'ai déjà parlé du renfort
roanne déjà parlé de la mallette de tous
qui avait donc là il ya le smartphone il
ya plein d'accessoires j'ai vraiment
hâte de voir ce que ça donne
aujourd'hui c'est pas le test
aujourd'hui on vraiment venir découvrir
un peu cet écosystème et on en reparle
dans quelques jours donc si vous n'êtes
pas déjà beaumier pourrait faire dès
maintenant
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
republic of gamer
[Musique]
je pense que ça va s'ouvrir bouton c
voilà ce que je vous dois aux oies la
vache
regardez-moi ça on a le rock sound qui
hélas mobile destock de display doc plus
combo rock kuna gamme pad qu'est ce
qu'on a ici ça c'est quoi c'est une
coque de protection tout une view doc 2
ça c'est quoi ce truc là je sais pas du
tout ce que c'est que ce truc là c'est
un sac pour tout transporter ok pas mal
toujours utile que vous avez lu logo
republic of gamer autres vous mettez
tout là dedans et vous partez à la vente
donc ça c'est cool on va commencer par
le commencement rock funk
j'avais vraiment hâte de voir ce
smartphone c'est qu'à une arrière
c'était un dr un des smartphones de
gaming les plus puissants probablement
le plus puissant qui avait vraiment
cartonné comme en effet cette année déjà
vu mais pas en vrai on garde le même adn
on va garder les les hauts parleurs en
façade pour avoir vraiment toujours plus
d'immersion c'est son point je sais pas
exactement combien il pèse mais c'est
franchement son poids design hyper
léchée vraiment bien rogge aérodynamique
système vachement cool il ya vraiment un
design de fous j'ai vraiment hâte de le
tester parce que c'est vraiment un
produit atypique mais c'est un produit
aussi qui vraiment vraiment bien ici de
l'usbc qui est déporté sur le côté ça
c'est assez marrant prise jack pour
l'allumer le bouton de volume hockey sur
le dessus absolument rien et ici pour
mettre votre carte sim double caméra à
l'arrière une caméra à l'avant ont
effectivement une bombe noire de chaque
côté qu'on va très bien comme ça mais ça
c'est normal parce que si un smartphone
de gaming il a par contre est que les
haut parleurs dans le monde si on a une
immersion une expérience qui coule déjà
sa dernière j'ai trouvé ça vachement
malin vous venez brancher votre
ventilateur qui s'y qui vient le
refroidir
c'est maintenant qu'un petit ventilateur
qui est juste là là qui va tourner et
qui va venir dissiper la chaleur parce
qu'on allait faire les gros sessions de
jeu là normalement devrait pouvoir venir
régler même la couleur en fonction de
votre équipe si je dis pas de bêtise ça
s'est vérifié on conserve quand même si
à la prise jack
l'usb c'est plutôt cool donc ils ont
reconduit le système plutôt bonne idée
et ça ce qui est bien c'est que c'est
inclus avec le produit c'est pas un
accessoire en plus pour le coupe ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on a ici d'avoir les câbles
on doit avoir de la doxa c'est la coque
pour venir inscrire oissel vachement
léger sa feuille de papier trucage
aurait pas bleu casser tout cas c'est
pas mal why not
on a ensuite ici de courval tiroirs de
cartes sim on va avoir toute la dope
enfance bonsoir c'est plutôt rare de
voir des docks comme ça sur les
smartphones c'est vachement bien
la carte de garantie qui se situe là et
ensuite on va voir les câbles donc ici
oh la vache
le bloc de charges énormes republic of
gamer avec de la charge en nuage est il
si vous avez dans votre câble ici usbco
l'aise les cecos qu'on a encore derrière
tout ça c'est vraiment un parcours ne
serait-ce que le déshabiller lui ce sont
les petits cash d'accord ready cash en
plus qui vont venir là si jamais vous
perdez vos cash cool et ça c'est quoi ça
pour me pose une colle
je ne sais pas je vais regarder ça de
plus près on a une vraie belle
expérience de déballage sur cette boîte
c'est vraiment très atypique pour un
smartphone atypique mais bon pas mal en
plus on a la pression c'est du papier
recyclé ou touchées donc ça c'est
vraiment cool
le smartphone a l'air vraiment vraiment
chouette je pense qu'il va être à la
hauteur de ce qu'on avec le rock phone
de l'année dernière que ce qu'on met
avec la retenue la dernière maintenant
on va juste un petit coup d'oeil rapide
côté les accessoires on va commencer par
sam au bail des stops doc je pense que
c'est le dog pound a revanche son
intérêt ah ouais c'est ça s'il avait
déjà vu il n'ya que les trouvais ça
vraiment cool au niveau de l'expérience
de la même manière garder vos évoque
petit dock là vous débranchez votre
smartphone une fois de plus en avant le
petit capuchon que vous avez là vous
venez vous posez votre mac votre
smartphone comme ça devant donc il vient
dans son dock vous avez ensuite
vachement de connectique pour mettre une
carte sd dessus qu'à regarder moi au dos
tout ce que vous avez comme connectique
hdmi s pdif vous avez deux usb vous avez
de l'usbc vous avez franchement de quoi
faire là vous venez vous le branchez sur
votre télé et là déjà l'expérience elle
va être vachement cool et je pense que
ça en plus vous devriez pouvoir avoir un
faut vraiment que je vois si vous pouvez
utiliser sept contrôleurs en plus pour
pouvoir le piloter avec ça à l'intérieur
on a quoi on a effectivement ensuite
tout un guide alors là croyez moi vous
avez vraiment de la documentation la
carte des garanties que vous avez
ensuite ça alors ça a l'air vachement
cool je pense que c'est ce qui va me
plaire
voilà au lapin et away
pas mal du tout j'ai ça je dois pouvoir
venir mettre sa d'un côté et de l'autre
donc une fois que tu es dans le dos qui
les envoyaient je peux venir utiliser ma
télécommande pour jouer avec mon
smartphone donc ça c'est assez cool
petit monde de joypad les commandes là
les boutons j'ai ça ici ça ici et des
gâchettes agents les deux là un la laddh
la gâchette des moutons la dernière la
vache la ilaha mais j'en ai vraiment de
partout là là avait donc là est vraiment
bien le paramétrer je pense en fonction
des objets et l'a ensuite voir d'autres
petits boutons profil fonction smart way
i price sera cool ensuite à l'intérieur
à regarde-moi ça je vais venir brancher
mon smartphone ici là avec la prise usb
ces jeux vient enlever cette partie là
d'un côté je viens enlever cette partie
à d'autres et je viens les intérêts de
chaque côté et là ça me fait un peu une
espèce de nintendo switch ça c'est
énorme c'est vachement grands il ya un
côté un peu lourd mais pourquoi par là
je pense qu'on va pousser l'expérience
du jeu vachement moins ça c'est vraiment
vraiment cool un très grand fan ensuite
qu'est ce que j'ai encore à l'intérieur
là c'est quoi ça un manuel d'utilisation
qui est bien moins épais que les autres
je pense la carte de gars entier est ici
un bon gros câble usb usb c'est à noter
qu'ici j'ai quand même une prise jack
ensuite plus petit mais non des moindres
on va voir la petite coque de
smartphones taxe vient la republic of
gamers très sympa fait de voir ce que ça
donne là dessus je continue de le type
et de laura c'est la cocasse et légères
le smartphone ya celle où on se dit
qu'est ce qu'on a ici alors celle là où
ça se complique un petit peu c'est quoi
ça
ging weegee displayed up plus combo de
cas résolution connexion internet très
rapide
là où latency comment ça sort ça qui est
bien là ok verlhac aucun s'asseoir comme
ça comme ça comme ça c'est quoi cet ange
en page d amy usb pour brancher et reset
bouton power puis qu'est ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur ça sel dans l'alimentation
non c'est un petit dongle ok rj45 usb ok
bon et pourquoi pas je pense que c'est
un petit dock pour avoir une meilleure
connexion internet ça on va se tester
donc on en reparle aussi d'ici quelques
jours et ensuite on va voir celui-là le
twin view doc 2 bien là non lapin toi tu
vas au fond alors qu'est ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur
ah oui mais oui oui oui ça je trouve ça
déjà coulé dernière vous prenez donc
votre smartphone
une fois de plus je vous enlevez le
cache en dessous bien évidemment vous
venez l'insérer délicatement en bas
comme ça et ce qui fait qu'en fait je
vais avoir les deux écrans pour jouer à
des jeux et ça je me souviens c'était
vraiment vraiment cool
alors on va regarder on va se
télécharger des jeux on va regarder
comment ça marche
utilisez les deux écrans un peu comme
une nintendo ds moi je trouve ça
vachement cool occasionnels bouton power
on a une bouton savez peut-être des
boutons de volume moi j'adore cet
accessoire ou l'emmener partout avec
vous ici en plus vous avez une petite
prise jack pour brancher votre casque
est ce qui n'est pas négligeable de
l'usbc pour venir charger je pense le
dock ça c'est quoi c'est pour le
verrouiller je pense à ces cinq là il
est verrouillé hop je le délai rouille
donc ça c'est vachement vachement cool à
gagny la patrie l'acquis en train de
m'alimenter le smartphone ici toute la
documentation on va s'allumer cette
petite bête
moi ce que j'aime déjà c'est
effectivement commis les races
effectivement j'ai cette bande en hausse
et bamba bon sens dérange pas mais là on
arrive sur quoi
ça envoie du bois quand même
donc là il ya déjà des jeux d'installer
il ya quoi asphalte 9 fortnight aura de
quoi se marrer on pourra installer
d'autres alger les infos hockey cpu gpu
la mémoire utilisée le stockage utilisé
j'ai vraiment hâte de prendre du temps
avec les airs trigger génie jeu la
vitesse du ventilateur le système
d'éclairage vachement de choses à
paramétrer c'est ça que j'aimais dans ce
smartphone déjà l'année dernière je
trouve toujours toujours intéressant
c'est qu'il est hyper hyper hyper hyper
optimiser tous les outils affectivement
même niveau des outils vous avez des
icônes qui sont extrêmement type et
calculatrice en loge compagne galerie
j'attends d'un fichier métaux phone
météo ça c'est vraiment cool dont
netflix et compagnie on n'en pas simple
j'adore un avion saisi kaunas est
vachement bien fait passer des coups de
fil ici l'appareil photo alors qu'est ce
qu'on a sur l'appareil photo encadrée
rapidement appareil photo grand angle
normal vidéo suivi mouvement
ralentissent à ces détails la bsaa le
mode portrait panorama manuel nuit ok
bon tout ça on va le tester un très très
très très très prochainement et
extrêmement prometteur
je suis très heureux complice
effectivement un boxer ensemble ce rock
von den aujourd'hui la neige avait
beaucoup peiné ce smartphone a
effectivement il n'est pas du tout
destiné à tout le monde si vous n'êtes
pas des moeurs c'est pas votre truc
gueorgui nos intentions je vous
conseille absolument pas c'est vraiment
un smartphone qui est typé queyras et
mais qui par contre est extrêmement
optimisée et qui offre un écosystème
hyper intéressant avec tous ses
accessoires alors je sais que tout ça
met bout à bout représentent un peu
d'argent vous n'êtes pas obligé de tout
acheter ça va dépendre de ce que vous
allez vouloir en tout cas faire mais air
trigger sont cool
il ya pas mal de choses intéressantes on
en reparle c'est quelque chose dont vous
invite à vous abonner parce que je vais
jouer
je vais jouer je vais jouer et je vous
donne mon résultat je débrief d'ici
quelques jours
sur ce je vous invite à venir rejoindre
la communauté monsieur brou vous avez le
bouton rejoindre le fou pour être
toujours plus nombreux plus nombreux il
ya plein de choses à faire ensemble à
plusieurs niveaux fait clic et vous
saurez tout et puis vous invite à vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait comme
ça vous saurez tout il ya tellement
surprise qui vont arriver le forum
toujours en cours de construction
ça prend beaucoup de temps mais ça ne
saurait tarder voilà on en reparle
bientôt vous embrasse donc pour les
soins de vote auto